minority leader in the House Nancy
Pelosi referencing this letter that
actually was tweeted out by the
President himself in which the first
announcement is made that the Singapore
summit is not going forward among the
outreach though is a future line in here
if you change your mind having to do
with this most important summit please
do not hesitate to call me or write the
world and North Korea in particular has
lost a great opportunity for lasting
peace and great prosperity and wealth
this missed opportunity is a truly sad
moment in history with that let's bring
in our panel from Washington
Tom Rogan commentary writer for the
Washington Examiner Amy Walter national
editor for the cook Political Report and
Molly Hemingway senior editor at The
Federalist Tom your thoughts on how it
all came down today well I think the
basic point here is that President Trump
is leaving clearly opening to towards
continuing this summit on June 12th as
had previously been arranged and I think
actually in my impression that is what
will happen and what I think you see
coming behind the scenes here is a
pressure calculation on the part of the
Chinese to see how far they can push
President Trump I think this
cancellation was directed at Beijing as
much as it was at Pyongyang but also on
the secondary part Kim jong-un
recognizing that the symbolism of his
attending the summit is as complicated
as some of the concessions that he might
be expected to make but I still think
ultimately this summit will go ahead on
June 12th well to that point Fox News
Alert here according to Reuters just
within the past few seconds North Korea
says Trump's decision to scrap u.s.
North Korea's summit is not in line with
the world's wishes and North Korea
saying it is willing to resolve issues
with the US according to state-run media
this develops you know by the day by the
hour
malee yeah I think this is disappointing
news but not completely surprising
particularly in the last couple of weeks
where you were seeing that North Korea
and the u.s. were really pretty far
apart North Korea was proposing
something more along the lines of what
we've seen in past decades where they
have an aspirational pledge that they
will eventually denuclearize and the US
was saying that's
gonna work anymore we wanted up front we
want accountability we want a clear
timeline so they were far apart and we'd
heard that communications had really
broken down but I agree with Tom you
know this is not the end of the line
this is part of the negotiation process
and so with what will be interesting and
what's interesting about this Reuters
report is I think people were careful to
see whether North Korea would say we do
want to make this happen and we're
willing to work toward it or if they
would respond with their old pattern of
nuclear missile tests and other
belligerent attitudes so but it's a long
ballgame still yeah Amy I mean we're now
getting an officially from the South
Koreans Yonhap that North Korea is
willing to talk with the United States
any time in response to this decision to
pull out of the plan summit saying that
they want to resolve the issues so I
guess you know you heard Senator
McConnell earlier say the next step is
North Korea's and it seems like this is
they're taking that step yeah this is
what's give me what I'm fascinated to
watch is the way in which Americans are
reacting to this take take away and just
sort of the back-and-forth here in
Washington but in in polling what we've
seen in the last couple of weeks is that
across the board this is Republicans
Democrats and independents we're giving
the idea of a sit down between the
president and Kim jong-un high marks
they liked this idea and in fact in the
last CNN poll the president's handling
of Korea was the thing that people saw
as the most positive thing he was doing
he got his highest marks on this so I
think overall what the American public
is saying is we kind of like this idea
we don't really know where it's going
we've never seen anything like this
before but let's try it what happens
though if this does go wildly off track
or if the summit never happens or if
there's more sable saber-rattling from
North Korea or South Korea does
something and we kind of if there is a
continuing sort of chaos does that then
ultimately impact the way that voters
not just see the president but
ultimately the way that he's able to
handle any other foreign policy or any
other foreign policy crisis right Tom
quickly wrap this up
yeah look again I think the North
Koreans know that they have an interest
in at least sitting down at the summit
Beijing wants that they want to see if
Trump is malleable the letter suggested
he is not I think it goes ahead and I
think ultimately that message that we've
just seen there is the north that is as
nice as it gets from the North Koreans
so you know of course for optimism
that's a love letter right panel thank
you